okay we got a big show
please
please you don't want to take time away
from martin and martin around
but uh listen where our national
nightmare is over andrew cuomo has
resigned uh this was
well it's a long time coming but it
finally happened this week he said he
didn't want to do it but he felt he was
forced to and all the women in the
office went
[Applause]
he said he needs two weeks to get out of
town
he's gonna be governor for two more
weeks well he says there's a lot of
things to do a lot of loose ends to tie
up you know administrative duties to
fulfill he also wants to take one more
shot at teresa at the zoning board
but
the other scandal that the democrats are
facing even though i don't think it's a
scandal at all but obama had a big
birthday party yes because he's
successful and he's 60.
this is america
we don't want to punish success do we no
we doubt anyway but yes it's true in the
pandemic with everything going on the
optics were terrible
and they should have known that the the
dj they hired was named tone deaf
uh
but and it was whoa what a talk about an
a-list crowd oh my gosh jay-z and
beyonce spielberg don cheadle tom hanks
bradley cooper john legend this was the
swanky party
a lot of them were tipping the valet in
bitcoin
but it you know it is bad optics because
first of all a lot of them flew in on
private jets
and we got a climate report from the u.n
horrible news as it always is nothing
you even need to read
right
about the cli just walk outside it's hot
oh it's hot i saw hunter biden putting
ice on a hooker's nipples and she was
paying him
that's hot ladies and gentlemen
before
poor hunter biden they just every they
keep releasing these videos of him have
you seen this always with the hookers
and the blow it's sad
wait sad yeah sad i'm sorry no yes sad
very [ __ ] sad
is what i meant to say but really i mean
this hunter biden
never have sex when he doesn't put it on
his laptop
most people when they have an orgasm
they say oh god oh god he says like
comment and share
but yes
but yeah against all the horrible things
that are going on i'm sure you saw the
taliban have now pretty much taken over
what we didn't we knew it would happen
not quite this fast they're taking over
afghanistan and and biden i'm telling
you look you know he's the one who did
this i think it'll look good in the
future but right now he's under a lot of
heat
so many things kovid's spreading and
this he doesn't he doesn't want to talk
about this [ __ ] he had a press
conference today first thing he said was
uh so how about all that crack my kid
does
hate
[Applause]
no it's sad afghanistan 20 years we were
there all for nothing it's like when
sean hannity went to high school
it's terrible
[Applause]
but yeah no we'll be living i just want
to say you think albany is a hostile
workplace
yeah wait till you see kabul
hostile workplace for women i think i
left that part out
either way it works but you're right i
should have mentioned that all right so
the 2020 census is out listen to this
white people have fallen for the first
time as numbers in this country since
1790.
uh i blame country music
[Music]
[Applause]
you just can't [ __ ] to it you know
but a lot of people see the writing on
the wall a cracker barrel
change their name to just barrel
you